>>UCKER: SO THE CITY CADEDASAREK
BILLIONS OF THEM.
ERE ARE SO MA BODS AROUND
TH PEOE STARTED EATG THEM.
NORMAL WE WOULD JGE ANYONE
WHO WOULDAT WINGED INST
BUT IA MOMEN LIKE THIS YOU'VE
T TO KEEP ANPEN MINDNDE
BRETAWSO KNOWS A LOT AUT
EATING BU.
HE'SROM FEWS HEADLINES.
'LLALK US THROUGH AASTE
TE.
GETS TSEE YOU.
>> TUCKER GOOO BE HERE
TH BRO X KD OFOUNDS LIKE
THE RAL GE AT THEIGH
SCHO QUA BUT THIS  THE
GROUPF CADEDAS THAT SHO UPEVERY.
2004.S TE WE SAWHEM WAS
THEY AREOTAB FOR THAT LOUD
UND THAT THEY MAKE
'S OFTEN HEA WN W GO TO
PRES CONFERENCESHROUGHOUT THE
WASHINON, C. AREA, WHE
'RE HEARING POLICIANS.
A HURED DECELS IOW LOU
IT'S INTEREING.
TH SOUNDS Y'REEARINGROM
THE CADEDAS IS T MATING CAL
OF T MALEICADA TO E FEMALE
TO GET THE GROOVE ONO THEY N
DROPHE BIES ITHE GROUN
D THEY WILL P OUT 1EARS
TER.
THEYRE EBLE AND WOT SOME
ADYOR YOU FROM E RISG
CREEK BERY IN MNT MOIS,
DELICIOUS TWES TRE INCLUDINGF
CADEDAS.
THEDA HAS SAI IFOU HAVE AN
ALLERGY TSHELLFISH, SIMP OR
LOBSR, CRAWL FISH TNGS LIKETHAT
THE DON'T EAT TH.
U'LLAVE AN ALLERGICEACTION
CAUSE THEY ARN THE SAME
FAMI BUT THEY ARE OTHERSE
SAFE TO EAST.
THEM TO EATHEM IN MODERATI.
IF YROG GS OUT IN THE
BAYARD AND GRABSEM.
ARE Y GNG TO TRYNE OF
THESE DELICIOUS COOKIES.
>> TKER:'VE GOT TOE HONES
WITH YOU, BRET MY PRODUCER LEFT
ME O TSE DK AND I NER
AND I ALRDY ATE ONE,T'S
ACTULY TRUE, IT S DELICIOU
JUSTO REASSURE OUR VIEWERS WHO
AR ON THE FENCE,HO ARE B
CURIS, I'M GOING T ITS.
THERE  ONEIGHT ON THETOP.
HONEST, IS DELICIOUS.I MEANTHAT.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BEHAT
BA
ONLINE FROM ALL THE CEL CHS,
TOSS ON A LITE SESE OIL AND
CHOPD GAIC.
DOUBLE-CHECK BOREOU'RE
EATING OTH BUGS BUT JUST KW
E CADEDASRE SAFE.
AL IN ALL TT AREN' THA BAD.
YBE EVERY 17 YEAE HA SOME INTES
INVOINGUGS T.TOO THENLY THING TS
IT F ME IS THAT BILL GES APPROV.
>> THEY HA BEE IN THE GUND